[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back breast cancer kills tens of
thousands of women in the u.s
every year but black women face a much
greater risk
of dying from the disease in today's
buddy check 8 report
denise valdez talks with a local
specialist about a growing concern from
doctors
who warned the disparity may get worse
[Music]
this is an alarming statistic
african-american women are
42 percent more likely to die of breast
cancer
than white women now there are a number
of reasons why
but now some fear the pandemic may even
widen that gap
this year many women postpone their
annual mammogram
and that puts african americans at even
greater risk
since they're more likely to be
diagnosed with breast cancer at
later stages of the disease they also
face more burdens at
every step of their journey the other
problem is just
awareness sometimes because of the lack
of
access and what some might call
institutional racism
there is not the uh
ability to get in
and see the physicians or nurse
practitioners the providers as fast as
one should
dr russell gallard medical director at
optum care cancer center
points out that black women are at
particularly higher risk
of developing the most aggressive breast
cancer triple negative
in triple negative disease is in many
ways
its own entity and has a very very
high rate of coming back even
after initial surgery and chemotherapy
dr gollard says studying genetics and
biology of breast cancer could go
a long way to saving women of color
there aren't many uh
genetic counselors uh
in the state of nevada nevada we're
lucky enough to
have one working with us here but but
yes
getting the appropriate testing and
seeing somebody
who can actually order that testing
interpret it and um you know i will say
this it's not only
important for the individuals who are
getting
tested but for their family members
besides biology
regular screenings are so important to
catching cancer early
and experts recommend a monthly breast
self-exam to detect any changes in your
body
for buddy check i'm denise valdez back
to you